un nouveau départ pour rudimentini s'est
affuteur rémouleur originaire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux a lancé en
octobre 2022 sa micro-entreprise et
filiforme au volant de sa camionnette
l'artisan parcourt le département pour
entretenir couteau ciseaux sécateur
aucun outil ne résiste à son regard
aiguisé
vous avez une pâte d'affûtage sur ce
marché de noflux le château
l'entrepreneur travaille à bord de son
atelier itinérant un geste de précision
redonnant son tranchant à l'outil pour
prolonger sa durée de vie quand le
Taillan commence à être un petit peu usé
à ce moment-là il faut le faire ce qu'on
appelle un aiguisage donc ça se fait
aussi sur un fusil donc là on a un fusil
avec un grain extra fin etc et puis
quand vraiment notamment les boucher
vont vraiment se faire de manière
intensive de leur de leur couteau au
bout d'un moment donc les visages ne
suffit plus donc il faut à nouveau
affûté ça c'est ce qu'on fait c'est des
métiers dont je me souviens quand
j'étais enfant et qui ont disparu au fil
du temps ou donc on a été pendant pas
mal de temps obligé acheter du matériel
neuf à chaque fois alors que maintenant
ça va permettre de de réutiliser du
matériel et d'éviter donc du gâchis du
gaspillage son grand-père bouché lui
transmet la passion de l'affûtage dès le
plus jeune âge après 26 ans passés dans
une grande entreprise du CAC 40 comme
responsable des services généraux
rudimentini décide de se reconvertir à
l'âge de 50 ans la plupart de ma
profession j'ai travaillé dans les
bureaux où j'allais sur les chantiers
mais je regardais j'en travaillais et
puis plutôt que de faire travailler les
autres j'en ai envie de travailler
moi-même de revenir un petit peu au
fondamentaux chose simples et puis
surtout être en contact avec les clients
le client final il semble déjà bien
affûté
d'accord il y a des gens qui viennent
comme on évoquait tout à l'heure qu'on
est des outils parfois avec une charge
affective importante donc c'est vraiment
le voir le soir des gens quand on leur
rend leur matériel à chuter améliorer
etc donc voilà c'est ça vraiment ça me
c'est quelque chose qui me fait plaisir
l'affûteur rémouleur cherche à
développer son activité auprès des
professionnels bouchées couturières ou
encore coiffeur font partie de ces
cibles pour pérenniser son activité
itinérante